vous avez remarqué qu'il y a des gens
qui sont que la weed enfin leur sueur
sans la weed
dans ces cas-là vous vous dites bah il a
fumé de la weed bah oui bah non pas sûr
l'odeur corporelle c'est comme un
cocktail dans notre sort on rejette
plein de substances odorantes
différentes le caca des bactéries qui
mangent notre super par exemple et ben
il y a un chercheur qui a analysé les
composants chimiques odorants de la
sueur et de la weed et il y en a une
dizaine en commun ça veut dire que si
vous avez les 10 dans le bon dosage bah
sans le faire exprès vous avez réussi le
cocktail parfait ça sent pareil ça
dépend de plein de choses ça dépend des
bactéries ça dépend de ce que vous
mangez mes résultats votre sueur elle
peut sentir la weed alors que vous fumez
pas de weed non mais non merci pas
[Musique]